مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
الانسانيه الخاصه في هذه النافذه نناقش
استمرار استهداف القطاع الصحي في قطاع غزه
اذ قصفت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي محيط
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى بينما اعلن مدير
منظمه الصحه العالميه عن الغاء المساعدات
الطبيه الى غزه بسبب مخاوف امنيه ودعى
اسرائيل الى الموافقه على طلبات منظمه
الصحه العالميه وشركائها تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه لمناقشه هذه القضيه سيكون معنا
من مجمع الشفاء الطبي في غزه الدكتور
معتصم صلاح عضو لجنه الطوارئ بوزاره الصحه
في غزه لكن في البدايه مشاهدينا ننوه الى
ما اعلنته وزاره الصحه في غزه بان قوات
الاحتلال ارتكبت 14 مجزره في القطاع خلال
الساعات ال 24 الماضيه راح ضحيتها
147 شهيدا
اضافه الى
243 جريحا وقالت الوزاره ان عدد الشهداء
ارتفع الى
2335 بينما وصل عدد الجرحه الى
59410 منذ بدايه منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي واشارت الوزاره الى ان 70% من
ضحايا العدوان الاسرائيلي اطفال ونساء كما
قال المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي ان هناك 7000
مفقود تحت الانقاد او مصيرهم
مجهول وزاره الصحه في غزه قالت ايضا ان
نحو مليون و900 ال نازح يتعرضون للمجاعه
وانتشار الاوبئه والامراض المعديه وانعدام
الماوى والماء والطعام
والدواء بينما يتعرض اكثر من 900 ال طفل
في في مراكز الايواء لمخاطر البرد الشديد
والجفاف وسوء التغذيه والامراض التنفسيه
والجلديه هناك ايضا 50 ال امراه حامل
يعانين من سوء التغذيه والمضاعفات الصحيه
اضافه الى 400 ال مصاب بالامراض المعديه
نتيجه النزوح كما يوجد 10 الاف مريض
بالسرطان يواجهون خطر الموت بينما اشار
المكت الاعلامي الحكومي الى ان قوات
الاحتلال اخرجت 30 مستشفى من
الخدمه اذا معنا من مجمع الشفاء الطبي في
غزه الدكتور معتصم صلاح عضو لجنه الطوارئ
بوزاره الصحه في غزه دكتور معتصم مرحبا بك
اذا ما زالت المستشفيات تستهدف من قبل
قوات الاحتلال وهناك على ما يبدو منع وعدم
اعطاء ضمانات امنيه لمنظمه الصحه الع
العالميه
لتقديم المساعدات الطبيه ما اثر ذلك على
الوضع الصحي المتدهور اساسا لا بل هو بات
في حكم
الانهيار
نعم بخصوص الوضع الصحي في داخل قطاع غزه
بعد تدمير كافه المؤسسات الصحيه وانهيار
المنظومه الصحيه بالكامل في قطاع غزه
تحديدا في مدينه غزه وشمال قطاع غزه ما
زالت اله القتل واله الذبح المستمر
للمدنيين وللاطفال العزل والامن
مستمر للاسف التحديات التي نواجهها في
داخل قطاع غزه امام مشهد ومراه من كل
العالم لا يمكن ان نتخيل حجم هذه التحديات
امامنا ونحن لا نستطيع تقديم الحد الادنى
من الخدمات الاساسيه من انقاذ الحياه
لهؤلاء الجرحى والمصابين وتفض فضلت وذكرت
في تقريرك عده محاور عديده وعده فئات سواء
الاطفال او النساء او الحوامل او الكبار
السن او اصحاب الامراض المزمنه المشهد في
داخل قطاع غزه مشهد لا يمكن وصفه لا يمكن
ان
تتخيل
مشاهد حالات الاطفال النزيف المستمر امام
اعيننا امام مراه ومسمع من الجميع ودون
ادنى المقومات ولا نستطيع تقديم ادنى
الخدمات الا لهؤلاء الجرحى امام هذه
الاعداد الكبيره من هؤلاء الجرحى في ظل
استمرار القصف المتواصل على كل المستشفيات
تحديدا اليوم كان هناك استهداف لمستشفى
شهداء الاقصى وباقي المستشفيات وبالتالي
المشهد التي الذي نتعامل معه حاليا في
داخل قطاع غزه مشهد لا يمكن وصفه ولا يمكن
ان نتخيله نعم انت تتحدث عن الاف الجرحى
الاف الجرحى الذين ينتظرون نعم نعم كنت
اود ان اسالك عن شمال القطاع بشكل بشكل
خاص دكتور لانه المساعدات حتى الى الى تلك
المنطقه تكاد تكون معدومه كليا اي مع كل
ما واجهته مناطق الشمال من اعتداءات
اسرائيليه وتدمير ومسح
لمناطق
باكملها هل لنا ان نعرف وضع شمال قطاع غزه
والمرافق الصحيه ان بقيت فيه مرافق صحيه
اصلا يعني بالنسبه لمحافظه غزه وشمال
مدينه
غزه نحاول العمل ليل نهار من اجل انعاش
بعض المؤسسات الصحيه من اجل انقاذ ما تبقى
من هؤلاء الجرحى الذين يصلون كل يوم حاليا
هناك مجموعه من المستشفيات الذي تم تشغيل
جزء من هذه المستشفيات خاصه بعض الخدمات
الاساسيه على سبيل المثال مجمع الشفاء
الطبي تم تشغيل ثلاث غرف عمليات هذه
الثلاث غرف عمليات كانت تسمى غرف عمليات
اليومي الواحد من اصل 20 غرفه عمليات فقط
لاجراء العمليات الجراحيه العاجله لانقاذ
الحياه لهؤلاء الجرحى تم تشغيل ايضا
الخدمات التشخيصيه وتم تشغيل جزء من هذه
الخدمات في داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي مثل
خدمه غسيل الكلى نعم ايضا تم تشغيل بعض
خدمات الولاده في مستشفى الصحابه و مستشفى
الحلو الدولي ايضا تم تشغيل بعض الخدمات
في مستشفى كمال
عدوان هذه المات التي تم تشغيلها لا ترتقي
ولا تلب الحد الادنى فقط اود ان اسال
عندما تمنع منظمه الصحه العالميه من ادخال
مساعدات الى شمال قطاع غزه و لا تعطي
ضمانات امنيه معنى ذلك بانها ستستهدف هذه
المساعدات فيما لو توجهت من
دون من دون اي ضمانات هذا الامر ماذا يؤثر
على تلك الخدمات التي اعدتم تشغيلها ولو
بالحد الادنى
باختصار
نعم يعني فيما يتعلق ببعض المساعدات التي
قدمتها منظمه الصحه العالميه هذه
المساعدات
مشكوره على تقديمها ولكن لا ترتقي ولا
تلبي ادنى المقومات الاساسيه نحن خلال
الخمس ايام الماضيه اخي الكريم تلقينا كل
يوم تلقينا اتصالات من منظمه الصحه
العالميه بان هناك تنسيق وسيتم ادخال بعض
كميات من الوقود والسولار وبعض شحنات
الادويه على مدار الاسبوع الكامل ونحن
ننتظر هذه المساعدات للاسف لم يصل اي
قافله من هذه المساعدات حتى هذه المساعدات
التي نحن بامس الحاجه لها قسم العمليات
الذي تم تشغيل الغرف البديله والغرف
الطارئه ستتوقف ايضا في ظل عدم وجود بعض
المستلزمات الضروريه على سبيل المثال بعض
الاجهزه والادوات الجراحيه لمرضى جراحه
العظام المثبت الخارجي لا يتوفر اي منها
في داخل قطاع غزه لاجراء هذه العمليات
الجراحيه فنحن ن ننتظر على احر من الجمر
ادخال هذه المساعدات ولكن للاسف لم تصل
الى هذه اللحظه نعم فكل هذه الوعود وكل
هذه الاتصالات بانه ستدخل الكميات حتى
الكميات التي تدخل لا ترتقي الى جزء من
الحد الادنى من هذه المقومات لا اعلم ماذا
ينتظر من الشعب الفلسطيني ومنا في داخل
قطاع غزه شكرا وما الذي يريد يريدونه في
ظل هذا النقص الكبير في كل المتطلبات
الاساسيه طواقم صحيه في جنوب غزه لا يسمح
لها بالعوده عدم توفر السولار عدم توفر
قطع الغيار تدمير الانظمه كيف سنري ان
نستمر وان نعيد هذه المستشفيات الى العمل
في ظل كل هذه العقبات وكل هذه التحديات
دكتور معتصم صلاح عضو لجنه طوارئ بوزاره
الصحه في غزه حدثنا من مجمع الشفاء الطبي
شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا ختام هذه النافذه
الى
اللقاء